Have you ever had anyone be attracted to you just because you have the disease
or is that all made up internet forums still? I mean,
I haven't experienced that at all.
Some topics are hard,
either the subjects are going accessible. HIV does not make people dangerous.
People are uncomfortable discussing them. So we found those subjects in person,
rented a space in Los Angeles and invited our audience and strangers to come in
and pass anything.
My name is Ray Ferazi.
I have HIV and I'm here to answer any questions that anyone might have about it,
HIV.
Hello? Hi. How are you? I'm good. How are you?
What was your first reaction when you, when you were first diagnosed? You know,
in movies when like it's a really like intense moment and suddenly, like,
it just becomes like tunnel vision and everything kind of like backs away.
I was in the doctor's office,
staring at my doctor and she just like drifted off a hundred feet away and it
was very like earth shattering for me just because I didn't know a lot about
HIV. And I thought I was going to be dead in like two or three years old.
Are you when you found out it was on my 27th birthday, I'm 34.
Any type of illness? Um, since being here.
Be positive. So when I was diagnosed, I actually was diagnosed with AIDS.
So I was really, um, I was sick. My lymph nodes were swollen.
I had rashes that were just popping up.
I was getting sick all the time with [inaudible] and so I was trying to get to a
doctor, but I didn't have health insurance.
Cause it sucks here and clear that it was important for me to stay on
antibiotics and medicine and to not like put myself in a
situation where I might get a cold or flu,
cause then I could end up in the hospital and possibly die.
Do you know the person who did give you HIV?
So I don't know exactly for sure.
I could have been infected with HIV from someone that I wasn't using protection
with. Uh, I did test negative after, but I tested so soon.
I wonder if it could have been in that window period where it doesn't show up or
it could have been from the person that I was in a three-and-a-half year
committed, monogamous relationship with who I later found out was cheating.
Oh. So I I'll never,
I'll never know who was the first person you told when you found out you were
HIV positive and how did they react? The first person I told was my mom.
I called her from the doctor's office, sobbing, crying,
and um,
you know, she was,
she was worried of course and upset and um,
and it wasn't coming from like a mean judgemental place. She was just, you know,
mother's fears ever since I came out as gay,
when I was 18,
that was a running fear in the back of her mind that I was going to get AIDS and
die. And I think there was jail somewhere in there for some reason.
I don't know where she got that connection from, but yeah. Yeah. She was like,
I'm gay.
So now you're going to end up in jail and AIDS and die as time went on and she
learned more about it and I learned more about it.
Then she realized that I'm going to be okay.
And that's kind of when she relaxed and she supports me and you didn't go to
jail and I, didn't not yet.
As a healthcare professional, I come in contact with, you know,
a lot of people with communicable diseases. Uh,
is there anything I could do to make your life a bit easier when we do meet?
Um, wow. I remember the first few times I went to go see a doctor,
the fact that a doctor would shake my hand without putting, sorry,
I'm getting emotional. Um,
without putting a glove on was like really impactful for me in the very
beginning. I think that's a big deal.
Just treating people like they're human and that it's not like an issue.
It's not a thing.
You're just another person with something that they're coming to see a
professional to get treated for. You know what I mean?
What is it like to like date now? It was tricky at first because I'm like,
do I put the status on the app that I'm using or the website or do
I tell them later?
And I decided not to put it on the apps and on my profile,
just because people are so quick to judge.
So I like to wait until there's like a face to face interaction with somebody
and then they can kind of get an idea of my energy and my vibe and like,
see that I'm like a normal human being and I'm quite the catch to in
the U S the CDC agreed that if you're undetectable, do you know what that means?
So if you're taking your medicine for long enough,
it basically stops the virus in its tracks and it stops replicating.
And it's not doing anything in your body. It's like hibernating.
When you're at that place, it's called undetectable.
And when that's the case for six months or longer,
then you can't give it to anybody. So, and I've been undetectable for years.
So I know that I can't give it to people. Um,
but sometimes it's like a psychological hurdle for someone else to get it.
Past. So this is sort of phrased weird, but like how much is this a part of you?
It's definitely a part of you. It's not all of who you are. So like,
can you speak anything about that?
I love that question. I agree with you a hundred percent.
It's just a small part of who I am,
but at the same time had this like really, really strong sense of purpose.
I know that there's so much stigma and misinformation and there's not enough
visibility out there. And that was like the primary reason why I was like,
I need to start being a voice for it and starting to talk about it on social
media and show the people, Hey, look, someone my age, who's normal and healthy.
And like living his life has HIV and it's it's okay.
Have you been discriminated against for having HIV?
Totally. Yeah.
I had a barber that I was going was seeing regularly last year, actually.
And the last time that I saw him, I told him that I had HIV.
I did advocacy work ever since that day forward,
he wouldn't respond to any of my texts. Any of my calls I'd call the shop.
He'd be there.
Wouldn't call me back and wouldn't tell me why or anything either.
So it was really hard for me because I didn't know, you know,
why the sudden silence and I, after a month and a half,
I kind of just figured out it's because of that. And I had to find a new barber.
We need to erase the image that we created in the eighties and the early
nineties of what HIV is no longer applies. It's like,
it's almost like it's a completely different virus now.
Never had anyone be attracted to you just because you have the disease or is
that all made up internet for.
I mean, I definitely happens.
There are people I know they're called bug chasers and they're literally look
for people who have HIV. I haven't experienced that at all. Okay. Yeah.
Has there been anything good? That's come out of being a positive.
It's funny because before I was diagnosed,
I had never bench pressed or dead lifted or squatted before.
And that's like the Holy Trinity of working out.
And now I'm doing my first pro men's physique bodybuilding competition.
So that was like a big thing for me to kind of like,
it was like a physical manifestation of me taking back my health.
And I don't know. I just, I just, I feel like I'm the happiest I've ever been,
to be honest.
Did testing positive reevaluate. How you think about that?
It reevaluated how I think about life.
Cause at first I thought I was going to be dead in three years.
It made me think about like how on a daily basis am I living
in my fulfilled? Am I doing what's important? What matters?
You know what I mean? When,
when I was faced with what I thought was impending death,
I kind of had to ask myself all those questions.
Well, I'm glad that you're here. Yeah.
It's not your they're not gone in three years and that he can live a fulfilled
life until you can die of old age. Exactly. Right. Very nice to talk to you.
Thank you.
Thank you, man. I really do appreciate it, brother.
It was lovely talking to you. Yeah, you too.
Yes.